if you open up the documentation you can
see a couple of examples of typical
screen widths then it suggests how you
can set up your layout folders that you
can have a different main activity
layout for tablets vs 4 handsets and
here we define tablets as having a
smallest width of at least 600 DP to
customize the UI further we can create a
layout SW 720 DP folder that way we can
have a different main activity layout
for 10-inch tablets vs for 7-inch
tablets vs 4 handsets so back to our
quiz we need to define activity main.xml
file in our base layout folder so that
we can accomplish this layout on the
phone this layout applies to both phone
portrait and landscape so we don't need
a special version of the layout in the
layout land folder we do also need to
declare activity main.xml in the layout
SW 600 DP folder that way it will
override the one paying you I and use a
2 pain you I in this case it will be
picked up on devices that have greater
than 600 GP in both width and height
that means 7 inch and 10-inch devices in
both portrait and landscape mode and
lastly we don't need layout SW 720p
because we don't have different layouts
for 7-inch vs 10-inch devices